we spent some time collecting data right
help me out we were in six groups
what did we collect what was the kind of
data we were looking at
here link thank you very much that was
group one groups two and three you're
doing stuff together what were you doing
heart rate and breathe so lung capacity
is what we're looking at right
there's one two and three how many
siblings group four was looking at
siblings and family structure
group five had where's jacob it was
hands it was hands and what was the
substitute
shoulder breath right and then group 6
reaction time that's right so they're
using you did the stopwatch theme didn't
you good
okay so you now have all of this data
and then what we started on and we're
going to finish today
was taking that data to try and answer
this question
am i normal and we need to do a bit of
analysis
right okay so for that reason
i wanted to call you back to something
you were looking at earlier in the year
and that's what this table
is about most of it will be hopefully
ringing a little bit of a bell
right we looked at three main ways of
taking a big group of data
and then boiling it down distilling it
into a single number so you could say
this group is
kind of all like this and we had three
of them we called them
measures of central tendency that was a
big important phrase
there were three of them and they all
started with the letter m
do you remember what they were
we've looked at some of them before we
looked at um the one we usually called
the average
what's the other special name for the
other the mean very good
okay so the mean was the first one okay
what's another one
the medium and then i heard another one
very good okay now these are all three
measures of central tendency okay
now let's just try and remember because
this was a long time ago
what are these abby
what do they actually mean right i
didn't mean that
um what's the definition for each one
for instance
how do you find how do you calculate the
mean yeah
okay good so you're going to add up all
of
the scores you've got and then you
fantastic so if you've got 27 people in
the class
you add up all 27 people's heights and
you divide by 27 and that's what the
average is
okay these are quite different how do
you find the meaning
of a set of scores okay very good so the
middle
so in order to know what the middle is
you have to have them in an order don't
you and we looked at how to sort out
data before using excel
right so then you look and you count you
make sure okay out of 27
you'd pick who would be the middle one
out of 27. it's a funny number isn't it
13 13. let's think about that
you want if you've got 27 people right
27 people you want to split half
above half below and there'll be one
person right in the middle
right so i'm guessing you want 13 people
above
13 people below so that would mean it'd
be the 14th
person okay so that's the medium there's
a question about that in um
in the cat two if you remember trying to
work out the exact order anyhow
that's what we need to do last one do
you remember what you made
good most common right
okay so these are what the measures are
or this is how you
find them right now what i want us to
think about this morning
and we're going to use the um the data
that you've got
is when you compare these right
each mode has its own each measure has
its own advantage
and disadvantage or plural as you'll see
in a second right
so depending on the kinds of data you've
got we all have different kinds of data
that will lean you towards using one of
these kinds
okay does that make sense so let's think
about this really quickly because
again we knew all this before this is
what's kind of new today
all right so what's great about the
average
okay i actually have your i want you to
put your data there
right um you had a look at hair length
and how long you could hold your breath
and all those kinds of things
you might remember if all you do is
select all your data it actually works
this out for you automatically and it
comes up down the bottom
okay so i happen to know he's got this
open darcy you've got your hair lengths
there right
can you select all of the um all of your
range of data all the numbers
and what does it give you what does it
calculate
you've got a hair length average there
down the bottom
in the corner have you got yours
yours are siblings right one okay hold
on this was um
siblings the mean
was one point two five okay i'll come
back to that in a second
haley it was
31.5 okay thank you yeah that's right it
rings a bell good
okay so i'll come back to the siblings
in a second
when you've got these means right the
great thing about a mean
this is its key advantage right is it
takes all of the data
every single piece of data right it
takes everything
into account it doesn't miss
any of them which is why if for example
what you do right now in your
spreadsheet
is you just select all of the data
except for one
right like maybe you leave off the
person on the bottom which i think is me
in most cases right if you take off just
a single person the mean will change
okay or if you add a single piece of
data as long as it's not
average again your mean will change
okay so it takes everything together
that's fine
but there's a problem there's a problem
and i'm going to show you with a bit of
different data because
i'm not sure what kinds of information
you actually have i'm going to show you
an example
okay so under here
in this green little box i've got the
average salary right
do you ever what's the name of the
formula that you used to work out the
average
monetary question start with an equals
what word am i going to put in
it's average very good okay so there you
go
now from here i could name all of these
cells or i could use my mouse and i
could select them
but in a second as you can probably see
by the design of this spreadsheet
they're all just going to be in this b
column right
okay so i have a bit of a bit of a
shortcut that excel uses to just say
everything in a column you just say b
colon
b so you can see what it's done it
recognizes it that's how it colors it
right
everything in this column whatever i put
in there close my bracket it's going to
give me the average
okay now an error is going to come from
a second i want to show it to you and i
want you to try and work out
what's happening by remembering
what the definition of an average is
okay ready watch
this is an error right that's what the
hashtag means right what do you think it
means jay
okay so the first suggestion might be
okay hold on
there's there's not a number up there
right so maybe it's trying to work
something out calculate something
and that's why there's a problem there's
an easy way to work out if that's the
issue right
just go up there and delete it
didn't fix it did it so that was a good
suggestion but in this
particular case happened not to bid the
answer so pair you want to give us
another suggestion nothing to worry
about
okay so at the moment i haven't put any
salaries in there's no data
why do you think that would give read it
have a look
what do you think this error means yeah
nothing to
divide but ah okay no data
nothing to divide by more specifically
right how did we say tom i think it was
you
who said how do you work out the average
you add up everything
right and then you divide it you divide
by how many people or how many pieces of
data
you've got and how many pieces of data
do i have none so
it's trying to divide by zero so that's
why it breaks okay but we can fix this
that's all right
let's say we've got a few salaries and i
have some data right so maya
earns 14 000 perhaps okay
congratulations
um abby adds you know five hundred
dollars less i dots and pay because
you know she was talking before so um
courtney i'll put in
i'll put in a few other figures here uh
i'll fine i'll be
generous okay yeah amy's amy's not here
today so i
cut her salary um jacob's also not here
today so cut her salary
um ash i'll give you that darcy
darcy has to pay like a tall tax or
something like that so sorry buddy
all right so what have we got so far
if i just undo through here right you
might notice
that because excel's doing the
calculations for you automatically
can you see what's happening to the
average every time you add a new piece
of data
it adjusts right yes it changes
but what i didn't mention is that the
last two employees
me are important employees that's why
they're at the bottom of this
okay um connor here
here is the ceo of the company right so
he actually earns
substantially more so
that's his salary right there okay
not bad not bad especially compared to
the rest of pianos right but there's one
more person
who's perhaps even more important ceo
and this is me this is me paying you
back for making the shortest person in
the class
so there's the cfo does anyone know what
cfo is see if there was a stand for
chief financial chief financials very
good
you don't even know what you're doing
yet you're waiting for me outside
okay thank you
mr samimi over there our chief financial
officer is
very important and this is maybe even
more important ceo
because he holds the purse strings right
so he decides
and i don't know if he's gonna get fired
after this he decides to make himself
gonna pay even more in this year because
he has the power
all right now let's just have a look at
what just happened again every time i
put in a little new piece of data
the average it changed let me rewind
because you might not recall what
happened
right go back two steps so the average
there the mean is fourteen thousand
dollars
that makes sense doesn't it you look at
these numbers 14
000 does seem pretty average it
represents this group of people
pretty well okay but then you add in
ceo and the average
rises right in fact the average is now
substantially over
all of these normal employees salaries
and if i add in
our last employee there it's way over
it's almost
double right what most of these people
have
so what's happened what's been our
problem
what do you call this kind of thing is
that is that a meaningful average
no no it's not is it in fact there's not
even a person
who earns anywhere close to this you're
either way below or you're way above
okay so this happens to not be a very
useful way to do it
these are called outliers right now i've
given you an example of
outliers who are above the average okay
and so they've thrown the average out
but you can have outliers the other way
same idea right this is the disadvantage
to working out a mean
outliers are going to cause you trouble
right
in fact these are kind of two sides of
the same coin right
because the mean takes everything into
account
it'll take outliers into account which
can cause you problems like this okay
enter the median okay the median's the
middle score
okay now i won't make you turn the
screen again but you guys can do this on
your data whether it's hair length or
lung capacity or whatever
we worked at average right and our
formula for it
was this
right equals here's my here's how you
worked out your averages right
average and then you opened your
brackets
and you put in the right cells there and
everyone's got different cells which is
why i'm not putting in any particular
data
to work out the median just take a guess
what do you think is the
name of the function for the median
median very good okay so again
right you write your function out and
then you put in now where are the cells
that you're using for your data
okay and it will spit out for you
immediately i'm just really
quickly going to show you what it is
here on this data
okay so have a look at that now this is
kind of interesting right i won't dwell
on this because we've looked at medians
before
who is earning fourteen thousand two
hundred and fifty dollars
who's owning fourteen thousand two
hundred three jobs
nathan um there's equal pay with
fourteen thousand fourteen thousand five
hundred sources dividing i mean it's
going
half okay so just to come back to the
answer to the question
no one specifically is earning that
exact amount of money but it's halfway
between
can you see who's at halfway between
looks to me like it's halfway between
ash and maya right
so there these either sides of the
middle and 14
250 is right there okay so here's the
great thing right
you've got this problem of outliers here
with the mean right
but the median he doesn't worry about
the outliers
okay it ignores outliers that's the
advantage here
and i'll prove it to you let's suppose
that um that cfo goes
mad crazy with power even more than he
already has right
and he decides to double his pay okay
190
000 is that right that's better
what happened to the medium
nothing happened to the media let me
just change it again just to confirm
right
it didn't move anywhere why not when we
changed numbers the mean changed every
single time
why didn't the median yeah because right
now
that's right he's still number one right
and perhaps more importantly
um the middle is still the middle
wherever it was which was
between maya and ash right so the top he
can take himself as far as he wants
right
or if we had someone who was a low
outlier same deal it won't change the
middle
okay all right so there you go that's
the um that's the main advantage here
now unfortunately you don't usually get
to take a spreadsheet into an exam with
you right
so we talked about this before how would
you usually how would you work out the
median
if i just printed this out and gave it
to you what would you have to do
you'd have to you'd have to count
wouldn't you number one you'd have to
get it into order
and then you'd have to count and that
takes a while it's time consuming
so that's kind of your main disadvantage
there